former president Barack Obama was out
campaigning for a number of different
2022 candidates he was in Georgia he was
in Michigan he was elsewhere as well I
believe and I have to tell you that it
was extraordinarily refreshing now I
know some of you will say hell but David
you neo-liberal liberal shill Barack
Obama used drone Warfare and I would be
with you a hundred percent and I was
critical of that when it was going on
but generally speaking Barack Obama made
clear that there was one party right now
that believes in democracy period no
matter what the outcome is whereas the
other party the Republican Party sort of
believes in it if they win but if not
then they believe in something very
different than democracy he spoke
passionately he absolutely crushed all
of the Republicans uh that were running
in those States and I don't want to
waste any time let's get right into the
first clip here is Barack Obama on
Social Security this was in Milwaukee
Wisconsin campaigning against Ron
Johnson for Mandela Barnes a very
important race is
some of you here are on Social Security
some of your parents are on Social
Security
some of your grandparents are on Social
Security you know why they have social
security because they worked for it
they worked hard jobs for it
they have checked hands for it
they had long hours and sore backs and
bad knees to get that Social Security
and if Ron Johnson does not understand
that
if he understands giving tax breaks for
private planes more than he understands
making sure that seniors who've worked
all their lives are able to retire with
dignity and respect
he's not the person who's thinking about
you and knows you and sees you and he
should not be your senator from
Wisconsin
every single one of this weekend's
speeches was this level of energy and
also this accurate about what it is that
these Republicans want to do here's
another brilliant one from Detroit
Michigan
the other day I I did not realize this I
did not I've read about this somebody
had to show it to me the other day a
video came out of Governor whitmer's
opponent claiming that Democrats have
been working for decades to topple
the United States because they're still
upset about losing the Civil War
Coleman restrictions were part of some
master plan to do this now
first of all
what
[Applause]
what what
I mean I know some folks go down these
rabbit holes on the internet they're up
too late
but that that's like a Subway tunnel
that that's that's deep
and that is indeed the way it works they
go down absolutely Bonkers conspiracy
theories now then he was also in Georgia
in support of Raphael Warnock against
Herschel Walker where by the way the
polling is looking increasingly
disastrous for Raphael Warnock but we'll
cover that momentarily uh and Barack
Obama making the case Herschel Walker
fine football player but Senator that
doesn't make any sense
of you may not remember
but Herschel Walker was a heck of a
football player
I mean I mean some of you are too young
to remember but in college he was
amazing one of the best
running backs of all time
but but here's the question
does that make him the best person to
represent you in the USA
does that make him equipped
to
weigh in on the critical decisions
about our economy and our foreign policy
and our future
let's do a thought experiment
let's say you're at the airport
and you see
Mr Walker you say hey there's Herschel
Walker Heisman winner let's have him fly
the plane
[Applause]
[Music]
you probably wouldn't say that no you
would not and indeed saying that he
should be one of 100 members of the
Senate making such important decisions
is insanity and sadly that's what's
going on Barack Obama making the point
that House Republicans are ready and
willing to impeach Joe Biden they don't
even really know why a record if they
get control of Congress they will spend
the next two years
investigating
President Biden and their political
opponents that's all they want to do
they see it as payback
and some some of them said that they
they're they've already got prepared
that they're going to impeach you uh by
they're not sure what for
but apparently that's beside the point
and you're laughing except
they've actually said that
they had literally said we're not sure
what the theory is but we're going to
come up with one in fact there's an
incredible clip from I believe it was a
New Hampshire debate which I played for
you where they were going around saying
what would you impeach Joe Biden for and
everybody agreed they should impeach
Biden other than one candidate but they
disagreed as to why they should impeach
him and they have absolutely no idea in
reality Barack Obama also making the
point that no matter what's going on out
there even an asteroid heading towards
Earth they want tax cuts for the rich
and they do
[Applause]
actual solution to it
well no I'll tell you
they want a gun Social Security
and Medicare and then give some more tax
breaks to the wealthy
and the reason the reason I know that's
their agendas listen that's their answer
to everything
when inflation is low what do you want
to do cut taxes
when unemployment's higher what do you
want let's cut taxes on the wealthy
that's going to solve that I was joking
down in Georgia if there was an asteroid
headed towards Earth
he's gonna land in like two weeks
if you went in the Republican caucus and
you said what do you want to do
well we need a tax break for the wealthy
that's going to help
[Applause]
I'm I'm only barely exaggerated I don't
even know that he is exaggerating I
think if there were such an asteroid
Republicans would say well let's I guess
do something about the asteroid but
let's remember once we survive the
asteroid we need to encourage business
growth and the way to do that is give a
tax cut to the rich I don't think it's
an exaggeration whatsoever Barack Obama
accurately pointing out that there are
two obsessions for Republicans right now
owning the libs and getting Donald
Trump's approval this hasn't always been
a partisan thing
my favorite President was a guy from my
home state of Illinois named Abe Lincoln
helped found the Republican Party
it used to be that there were GOP
members who championed progress and
civil rights and rule of law
folks who who were with me in the 2008
election you remember right we we talked
about bringing people together and and
and spoke to all people regardless of
party about how we could move the
country forward
so so that's my instinct
I I I'm not
some buddy who believes
that all that some party label defines
this
but I but I I have to speak the truth
which is these days
just about every Republican politician
seems obsessed with just two things
own the lips
yeah let's own the lips
and and getting Donald Trump's approval
that's their agenda no no no don't boom
boom yeah
um he does warn Barack Obama does
Mandela Barnes you'd better be ready
with that birth certificate my friend uh
I wanna
say something here uh
I know that there's some folks probably
maybe not in this Auditorium but
elsewhere in Wisconsin
who think and I know these ads are
running this way that
just because
Mandela's name Mandela
[Applause]
but just because he's a Democrat with a
with a funny name
he must not be like you
he must not share your values
I mean we've seen this
it sounds pretty familiar doesn't it
[Applause]
sounds so Mandela getting ready to dig
up that birth certificate
[Applause]
yeah
um love him or hate him on his politics
uh former president Obama is very very
good at this now will it be enough to
turn around some of these races I wish I
could say yes let's take a look at some
of the latest polling
one of our sponsors today is feels feels
is a premium CBD designed to help you
feel your best delivered right to your
door with everything going on in our
daily lives we all need to take a moment
to relax and that's where feels comes in
many people report CBD helping with
anxiety stress and sleeplessness if you
have aches or pains there are people who
use CBD as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels CBD oil is awesome the CBD infused
mints are great they leave you with
fresh breath you can try feels caffeine
free Focus melts to get you through the
afternoon slump feels even offers a free
hotline with experts to give you advice
about CBD dosage finding the right
starting point and when you join the
feels monthly membership you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member to
day and get fifty percent off your first
order with free shipping when you go to
fields.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below